the graph above shows the number of
george's unsold candy bars over a 10-day
period
the points on the graph all lie on which
of the following lines let's see as the
days go by he has fewer and fewer unsold
candy bars all the way until we get to
day 10 and he sold all of his candy bars
because he has no unsold candy bars left
but anyway they want us to figure out
what could be the graph of the line or
the points on the graph all lie on which
of the following lines let's just think
about let's just think about this line a
little bit
let's just think about it's this line a
little bit so when we're thinking about
any line we could think about well
what's what's the slope of this line
going to be
so let's see our slope
our slope is our change in our vertical
axis for given change in our horizontal
axis
and so let's say that we pick the change
in our horizontal axis
to be 10 10 days go by so our change in
a horizontal axis is 10 days and so what
was the change in our vertical well the
change in our vertical was 120 candy
bars or negative 120. so we went down
when number of days increased by 10
positive 10 our candy bar is decreased
by 120
decreased by 120 and so what's that
going to be that's going to be
that's going to be negative
12. so we want a line with a slope of
negative 12. and immediately when you
look over here you know we could already
start to think about the y-intercept but
immediately when you look over here the
slope is going to be the coefficient on
the x so here this is a slope of
positive 10. that's not right slope of
positive 10 that's not right slope of
positive 12 not negative 12. that's not
right slope of negative 10 that's not
right and right over here we have our
last choice slope of negative 12 so our
choice is e but we could keep going even
if even if this was a free answer we
could still figure this out because we
know that the slope of a line or the
equation of a line is y
is equal to your slope
your slope
times x plus your
y-intercept
now we already figured out that the
slope right over here is negative 12 and
what's our y-intercept
well that's what y is equal to when x is
equal to zero when x is equal to zero
when no days have gone by george has got
120 candy bars
so this right over here is going to be
120.
so the equation of our line is going to
be
y is equal to even if we didn't have
these choices
y is equal to negative 12
times x plus 120
or you could obviously swap these two
around and write it as 120 minus 12x
which is exactly what they did right
over here